this is tan Mon performing her brand new
single hmm it is called what is it
called again tree to be me free to be me
with a live performance I'm gonna hit
the track now and as tan mom is gonna
perform you want a little water oh you
got water okay I'm just my mouth is so
dry your braless sexy don't let your
titties pop out could I have a little
bit of water too before
oh yes you leave here it is Tam I'm
singing live in studio to attract here
we go
[Music]
Tenma Tan mom Tan mom mom it's the
chicken she's free to be put your sugary
you see you see
[Music]
but I've been through but here's a
little message to you I want how would
you know oh my god I'm giving up are you
sure the plate in your head yeah surely
mom should sing take 22 what happen Adam
the malai performance this is reminds me
of shattered lives when Ashley Simpson
on a screw-up us tan mom was here to
prove that the new song is great you did
your part Adam what went wrong in your
producing uh when you figured this whole
thing out I think she just got a little
nervous I think maybe we'll try more
time all right well she's gonna look at
me we're gonna sing to each other I
think Robin it can happen to the best
problem
I know how this is yeah you perform you
know all right I'm gonna start it again
Shirley mom is that okay all right here
we I noticed in the beginning you say
tan mom Tan mom came on and then
Patricia goes no no no I'm Patricia
Marie yeah there seems to be a rejection
of the tan mom yes oh yeah free to be
nutrition I'm free you're free to be
Patricia Marie okay I get the song Robin
you ready I'm ready I'm strapped in are
you drinking more water it's really
dangerous when you drink water
all right here we go wrong my god okay
choke before you sing item is that for
now not all technique I singing coach
all right here we go
[Music]
Tan mom Tan mom Tenma Tan mom tenho
Tendo it's Patricia she's breathe be
Patricia Marie you see you see
all I want is to sing to you to tell you
what I've been through there's a little
message to you who's drivin a shower no
I think you cracked from the pressure ya
know it's pretty good backpackers okay
okay what is that you were rejected as a
wack pack no I love the song is she's
rejecting tan mom and the wack pack
trying to reinvent yourself wait that's
why part of is moving Florida I don't
want to alarm you but the plate is
sticking out of here